[Music]
who could you talk to that could help
them get through the city who could you
talk to that could help them navigate
checkpoints who could you talk to that
could help them actually see where the
checkpoints were who could you talk to
that could pull them through a hole in
the wall
of the cobble airfield
that's been there for a long time and
only that person on the wall knows it's
there who could you talk to from your
former experience with the state
department that could help get them
manifested
and that is what happened
monumental decision about america's
longest 20 years 2400 american military
u.s troops are leaving afghanistan
when you move the chess piece on the
board somebody else moves into that
position who is that
taliban and al qaeda from regaining a
terrorist there's been no let up in
fighting trust the capacity of the
afghan military
is now in control
the stunning collapse of afghanistan
plays out in real time
we're ending america's longest war
it started i think more or less with i
just want to get my guy out right some
guy who was working hard to to get a
single person out and that grew and grew
and grew things were so chaotic and we
were we
you know people say all the time we were
building the airplane in flight we were
designing envisioning i mean
buying the parts welding there was no
airplane to build in flight and we just
kind of took off and people started
throwing parts up to us i think we very
quickly realized
like
as a result of our actions those first
few days like 13 14
even 15 um that our government
didn't have a real plan and and most
especially didn't even have
communication
with a lot of the families that we're
trying to get out including american
citizens
lawful permanent residents
and especially sivs as well
and so i think that's when we realized
gosh we might need a lot of people
trying to support this effort
and so as as early as like the 14th 15th
we started to refer to it as like a
digital dunkirk i didn't know any of
these guys prior to like you know two or
three weeks ago um you know i was just a
low-level like captain in the army and i
think this group we referred to them as
the graybeards from like early early day
one and you know worth is only probably
like 11 years older than me but you know
his depth of experience in the military
was far more significant than my own
like yeah there's like six of us and
this is what we want to do what do you
guys do he said uh well we've got about
90 volunteers and we've got a virtual
joint operation center that's running 24
7 and we're building a database on all
these evacuees and you know etc and i it
took me the length of that phone call
one for him to have then amassed 150
volunteers not just 90
and me to go
okay you've got a better organization
you know what you're doing more than we
do and you're going to be more effective
in this digital space how can we support
you
and he said well we need connections and
we need aircraft and i said well that's
something our crew can do for you task
force dunkirk was kind of the command
element but that really implies that we
were far more in control than we were
which we were not we were a coordination
element
we were a bunch of older guys with a lot
of connections and a lot of numbers in
our phones
who could call and break down
barriers
the team america folks are younger
faster more nimble and vastly more
knowledgeable about how to use social
media and use the digital space to good
effect
and that allowed us to then kind of be
on qualifiers for them so when they
would find that hey we don't we we can't
get some people through a gate or we
need some leverage
to do x y or z okay got it we know who
to call we know what general we know
what person what undersecretary handles
that
and we may not know the under secretary
but we probably know somebody that works
for them there's a lot of
stuff out there that we didn't do
that's been assigned to what we did and
i want to clarify we were never on the
ground
we never parachuted in or helicoptered
in or any of that right it all started
with a couple of us who came together
to try and save one afghan commando
named nazan what we did was you know we
that team of teams thing it makes a lot
of sense we recognized that what we
needed to do was to make as many
connections many as many relevant
connections as we could remotely
with the different components that would
help these at-risk afghans move through
the various challenges along the way we
even established an underground railroad
in some places where they were pulled
through by the other side and you had to
have extreme discipline to do that to
show a pineapple on your phone when you
got the near recognition symbols at
night moving through a canal full of
sewage
you know and i think that it was it was
all of those factors combined that
allowed us again to know who they were
where they were and having the trust to
help them move and so with all of us we
had a lot of connections we had
connections through the city we had
connections on the other side of the
wall
and that's what was needed we needed to
be his eyes and ears we needed to be
he was the one taking all the risks
but we were the ones that could be his
eyes and ears and see around corners and
that's really that's really what
happened and to say it any other way
like would be disingenuous and it would
be a disservice to nazang and all those
other you know all those other afghan
families that really endured the risk
that really went through it
um we just tried to help guide them
that's we were guides
and and i think anyone on any of these
other task forces would say the same
[Music]